der eurovision song contest kommt nach
israel
mit ihren siegen lissabon vor einem jahr
holte die sängerin netra den wettbewerb
ins heilige land
[Musik]
ich bin stolz und geehrt diese magische
veranstaltung nach israel zu bringen
zwei wochen vor der großen show ist in
tel aviv von der magie noch nicht viel
zu spüren
immerhin am strand steht schon ein foto
rahmen mit dem motto get to green waage
zu träumen man muss aber kein träumer
sein und sich in tel aviv den perfekten
erste vorzustellen mit ihrer liberalen
atmosphäre ihrem stadtstrand und ihren
partys ist die metropole am mittelmeer
für den musikwettbewerb geradezu
prädestiniert schon jetzt feiern ihr esc
fans wie ihre shalev woche für woche
eurovisions partys
tel aviv ist eine offene stadt und sehr
sexy
sie ist wirklich extrem schwulen
freundlich es ist eine stadt in der ein
schwules paar hand in hand die straße
runter laufen kann ohne dass irgendwer
mit der wimper zucken wurde zudem ist es
eine richtige hipster statt
ich glaube daher dass der eurovision
song contest perfekt hierher passt vor
allem ist der esc in israel seit je her
ein nationales ereignis auch in tel aviv
haben sich bereits unzählige freiwillige
helfer gemeldet
und die jeweiligen sänger wie in diesem
jahr kobe marie tragen die erwartung
eines ganzen landes auf ihren schultern
es ist unglaublich zu wissen dass ich
nun dabei bin ausgerechnet in meinem
land in meiner stadt tel aviv unfassbar
eine riesige ehre für mich
was sein sieht auslösen kann hat die
zacken erlebt der musiker gewannen den
esc 1978 zum ersten mal für israel bis
heute ist krohn eine legende und sein
song von damals wird noch immer mit
gesungen
[Musik]
für die israelis war mein sieg damals
wie ein erdbeben
die leute waren so stolz so glücklich
auf den straßen wurde tagelang gefeiert
die israelis feiern ihre esc siege wie
fußballweltmeisterschaften so auch das
letzte mal als dana international den
esc von 1998 als erste transsexuelle
überhaupt
doch woher kommt diese begeisterung
der schriftsteller geriet dessen roman
monster gerade auf deutsch erschienen
ist setzt sich in seinen büchern immer
wieder mit der seele seiner landsleute
auseinander
für ihn hat es mit der geschichte
israels zu tun
[Musik]
die israelis wollen von der welt geliebt
werden respektiert und anerkannt
wir sind provinzler weit weg von den
zentren der zivilisation und wir haben
ein ungelöstes problem mit europa wir
wurden verjagt und umgebracht von
europäern dsc öffnet einen weg zurück
nach europa wir können teil des
geschehens in europa seien den esc zu
gewinnen ist deshalb ein riesending
eigentlich müssten nun alle an einem
strang ziehen um den esc zu einem erfolg
zu machen
stattdessen ist der wettbewerb in israel
zu einem politischen zankapfel geworden
so liefern sich der konservative
premierminister benjamin netanjahu und
seine regierung eine fehde mit dem
öffentlich rechtlichen fernsehsender
kran
sie mögen die freie presse nicht und sie
mögen vor allem den sender kann nicht
netanyahu hat daher versucht ihn zu
schließen
als das nicht ging wollte er wenigstens
die nachrichtenredaktion vom rest des
senders trennen
ausgerechnet kann produziert aber den
esc zwar konnte die zerstückelung des
senders mit hilfe der europäischen
rundfunk vereinigung ebel die den esc
veranstaltet verhindert werden trotzdem
gerät das produktionsteam immer wieder
unter politischen druck
so verweigerte die regierung die
finanzierung und bezahlte keine rechnung
für die produzentin zivis davidovitch
ist das frustrierend
am ende hat die regierung nichts bezahlt
sie gab uns nur einen kredit
ich finde das rätselhaft und ich
verstehe es nicht vor allem nicht als
bürgerin israels als netter letztes jahr
gewann hat sie das land vertreten und
nicht den center kann aber gut so ist es
nun mal
dabei ist der esc für die israelis auch
ohne streit ein gewaltiger logistischer
aufwand fast alle bauteile für die show
müssen per schiff oder flugzeug ins land
gebracht werden doch jenseits der
querelen rund um die israelische
innenpolitik hat der esc inzwischen noch
ein ganz anderes problem
er ist auch im israelisch
palästinensischen konflikt zwischen die
fronten geraten
denn die pro-palästinensische bts
bewegung die dafür kämpft dass der staat
israel mit boykotten investitionsstopps
und sanktionen belegt wird ruft zum
boykott der veranstaltung auf
einer der initiatoren ist der
palästinensische aktivist omar barguti
[Musik]
der staat israel begeht okkupation
ethnische säuberung er belagert gaza
verein zivile grundrechte inklusive die
der palästinensischen flüchtlinge israel
profitiert vom esc in tel aviv
es lässt sich reinwaschen als wäre
israel ein normales land mit einer
lebhaften kunst und musikszene
aber das ist es nicht es ist eine
besatzungsmacht die seit jahrzehnten in
besatzung und apartheid verstrickt ist
es sollte nicht mit dem esc belohnt
werden auch einige prominente musiker in
europa sind für boykott doch die bds
bewegung ist hoch umstritten denn sie
setzt sich nicht nur für ein ende der
besatzung der palästinenser ein die
israel seit 70 jahren aufrecht erhält
sie will auch ein rückkehrrecht für alle
palästinensischen flüchtlinge
in israel wird sie deshalb von
aktivisten wie nie zahner da schon
leitner bekämpft wir glauben dass bt es
im grunde antisemitisch ist es ist
einfach nur ein weg den staat israel zu
zerstören
wenn man auf die bds webseite geht
erkennt man dass sie den jüdischen staat
durch einen palästinensischen ersetzen
wollen
sie glauben nicht einmal an eine
zwei-staaten-lösung sie wollen einen
staat und zwar palästina leitner will
daher dass die regierung bds aktivisten
während dem esc nicht einreisen lässt
rechtlich wäre das möglich doch der
veranstalter die europäische
rundfunkunion kurz eu würde das nicht
hinnehmen erklärt der vorsitzende frank
dieter freiling
das würden wir nicht tolerieren und
akzeptieren können denn das ist teil der
garantie die und der premierminister
schriftlich vor zehn monaten gegeben hat
dass jeder der zum esc kommen will sei
es delegation sei es journalist sei es
fern auch kommen kann ungeachtet
politischer ansichten aktivitäten und
engagement aber bds mitgründer barguti
setzt auf andere mittel bei bds arbeiten
wir vor allem mit moralischem druck wir
gehen nicht hin und machen darin etwas
womit jeder rechnen würde
stattdessen machen wir moralischen druck
damit die menschen nicht zum esc reisen
zwar hat noch kein esc teilnehmer
abgesagt doch israelische künstler wie
der schriftsteller sari bekommen die
auswirkung der bds boykott kampagnen
längst zu spüren
[Musik]
palästinenser aus den besetzten gebieten
wollen sich nicht mit israelischen
künstlern treffen
das ist wirklich traurig ich habe selbst
versucht palästinensischen
schriftsteller aus ramallah jenin oder
gaza zu kontaktieren
aber sie wollen keinen israelischen
schriftsteller treffen
immer wieder ruft bds zu kultur bei
cotton gegen israel auf doch wie kommt
das bei den palästinensern selbst an
in ramallah findet die palestine music
expo statt eine art branchentreffen der
lokalen musikszene
[Musik]
zwar wird am rand der veranstaltung für
einen anti sc gewannen unter den
musikern selbst gehen die meinungen aber
auseinander
für palästinensische künstler gibt es
keinen startplatz
ich habe keine klare meinung dazu
weil ich eine palästinenserin binde in
israel lebt aber ich gehe nicht an dem
esc ich fühle mich nicht zugehörig
ich bin neidisch ich möchte teil des esc
seien in tel aviv oder irgendwo wer zum
esc kommt wer hier auftritt legitimiert
einen ort an dem andere menschen
unterdrückt werden
die palästinensische gesellschaft ist
genauso voller brüche wie die israelisch
das macht sich vor allem unter multi
sexuellen und quiring palästinensern
bemerkbar für sie ist das offene
liberale tel aviv trotz pds und
besatzung an anziehungspunkt auch für
den aktivisten gerade abus aus tel avivs
arabischen stadtteil jaffa sei fühlt
sich als palästinenser lebt aber in
israel und liebt tel aviv einen boykott
des esc lehnte ab
der esc ist eine wichtige sache
warum etwas boykottieren was so vielen
menschen freude macht nicht alle
israelis verdienen es blockiert zu
werden und dass der esc nicht her kommt
genauso wenig wie alle palästinenser die
besetzung vettel auch die politik
stattdessen hilft seinem israelischen
freund dabei tel avivs erstes schwules
hotel aufzubauen
ausgerechnet dem arabischen
bis zum esc soll alles fertig sein damit
israelis palästinenser und touristen
gemeinsam feiern können
doch die politischen debatten und
konflikte sie werden diesen esc bis zum
ende begleiten
[Musik]